when you look up at the night sky what
do you see
maybe it looks like a random smattering
of dim lights or perhaps you see in the
stars the shapes that can predict your
future if you're nerd like me then you
see a field of data and numbers that
reflect the quantitative reality of our
universe
to our distant ancestors unimpeded
access to the celestial sphere was
almost like a god-given right in fact
when many of them gazed at the stars and
the dark spots in between they did see
messages left for them by their gods
what exactly were those messages and how
have our interpretations of them changed
over time
when i decided to study both
astrophysics and mythology in college
everyone assumed i would be focusing on
astrology or constellation myths well
jokes on them because i can still only
reliably identify a single constellation
it's all for you orion
but along the way i have developed a
real appreciation for the role that
constellations and their myths play in
adding to our understanding of the
physical universe before we had gps
weather balloons and smartphones humans
relied on constellations to keep track
of time predict weather preserve culture
and navigate as they spread around the
globe they also use the stars to
foretell the future and commune with
their gods which seemed much more
reasonable at a time before humans
discovered physics this practical and
religious knowledge was encoded in myths
the ojibwe people native to the great
lakes region in the u.s tell a myth
about the fisher constellation
long ago the world was covered in snow
and ice and there were no birds to
announce the coming of spring
the fisher was a great hunter who went
up to skyland to free the birds and
bring warmth back to the earth when the
sky people caught fisher freeing the
birds they started to chase him but he
escaped to the sky where he was trapped
forever by an arrow through his tail
this ojibwe myth serves multiple
purposes it explains the changing of the
seasons and the constellation it's
attached to acts as a reminder of
spring's return no matter what they used
the constellations for the fact that
ancient humans used them at all meant
that people were studying the sky the
brightest minds around the world took
meticulous notes about how the sky
changed over time and without those
early astrologers the field of
astrophysics as we know it would be
drastically behind
i would probably lose my astronomers
card if i didn't tell you this at some
point so here goes
our planet is just one of many orbiting
a star which is just one of billions
orbiting a galaxy which is itself also
just one of billions in the vast
universe the points of light that we see
in the sky are distant stars and despite
what the myths may tell us their
arrangement is nothing more than a
coincidence
based on early written records and
physical artifacts most historians agree
that ancient mesopotamians were among
the first to observe the motion of stars
in the sky and assign divine meaning to
it because the sky was believed to be
the home of many gods the shifting
shapes in the inky darkness were
interpreted as omens like an omnipotent
teacher scribbling on the blackest of
boards
babylonian skywatchers in the 18th
century bce were especially prolific in
their study of the heavens the
babylonians and their neighboring
assyrians also gave us many of the
constellations we use in the west today
like the crab the bull and the twins but
we would call them cancer taurus and
gemini ancient mesopotamians even
invented the zodiac the sequence of 12
or 13 constellations that the sun
appears to pass through over the course
of a year though the sequence's name and
its association with horoscopes were
added by the greeks almost two millennia
later originally the zodiac was used as
a way to keep track of time the
mesopotamian constellation myths
trickled into egypt over a few hundred
years after it was conquered by persia
and then alexander the great in the 6th
and 4th centuries bce
these new myths merged easily with the
egyptians existing beliefs because they
had already been using the patterns of
the night sky to keep track of time for
practical reasons most of them having to
do with farming
when sirius the brightest star in the
sky appeared over the horizon ancient
egyptians knew that it was almost time
for the nile river to have its annual
flood which would nourish the soil for
the next year's crops
the constellation mythology spread to
greece by the third century bce where
they were called catasterismi meaning
placing of the stars because they
believed that the constellations were
put in the sky purposefully by the gods
to teach them lessons the greek's
religious fervor combined with their
taste for numbers produced astronomy the
meticulous and mathematical observation
of the sky you know so that we can know
exactly how the gods want us to live our
lives
unfortunately greek astronomers like
ptolemy spent all that effort describing
a system that relied on a fundamentally
flawed assumption they believed the
earth was the center of the universe and
that belief held as both astrology and
astronomy made their way through the
islamic world and over to europe where
geocentrism remained popular until the
heliocentric revelation in the 1500s
nowadays around 70 million americans
claim to read their horoscope every day
and nearly a third believe that
astrology is real or vaguely scientific
as a scientist i don't love those stats
but astrology in western countries is
mostly a novelty an interest that people
might use to help them make small
decisions
but different astrologies developed more
or less independently in china and india
each with their own constellations and
interpretations
astrology is still popular in some parts
of the east like in china where star
charts may be consulted to determine
compatibility and love or to make a big
career decision
in india astrology is used by many to
dictate decisions about medicine
marriage careers business deals often in
a harmful and discriminatory way i've
always thought it was kind of a shame
that conversations about constellations
are so often dominated by the greeks
because some of the most beautiful views
of space can only be seen properly from
the southern hemisphere you can see the
blurry magellanic clouds and the dark
rift cutting across the stream of the
milky way and because the stars you can
see depend on your latitude you can even
see different constellations like the
southern cross celestial navigation in
the southern hemisphere is inherently
more difficult than in the north because
there's no south star that stays put as
the rest of the stars appear to twirl
around it
instead they have the crux a small group
of four stars
despite this difficulty polynesian
wayfarers use the southern stars to
travel around the pacific ocean more
than a thousand years before europeans
traversed it using their compasses
in the time of ancient greece before
polaris was our north star the crux was
visible from more northern latitudes but
the earth's axis wobbled and now the
crux is a quintessentially southern
constellation one that features on
several southern countries flags like
brazil samoa new zealand and australia
some scholars believe that the
astronomical record in australia goes
back 65 000 years but the timing is
hotly debated
the aboriginal and torres strait
islander people are spread between
several hundred different language
groups with a wide variety of spiritual
beliefs and lore
despite their many cultural differences
cave paintings and other archaeological
evidence show that many aboriginal
australians were using stars as
calendars for more than ten thousand
years before the babylonians read their
motion as omens and in a time before
written language was developed the user
manual for these celestial timekeepers
was passed down through oral stories and
other art forms
one constellation common to many of the
aboriginal cultures is the emu whose
head was the dark coal sac nebula
nestled next to the southern cross the
emu's legs stream out behind her and
some stories say this is because the imu
used to have great wings that it used to
fly across the sky
the emu constellation's appearance in
the sky coincided with egg laying season
for the more earth-bound emus
those eggs are an important source of
nutrients for the aboriginal australians
and so the constellation was a
life-saving reminder
the pleiades star cluster is known among
many groups as the seven sisters though
the details of the story vary across the
continent the sisters are usually said
to be running from something maybe a
hawk or an unwanted suitor the yamaji
people in western australia used to
predict how heavy the seasonal rains
would be based on how bright or faded
the sisters looked in the sky
to some aboriginal cultures the stars in
the western constellation orion form a
canoe according to the yongnu people in
the muwat region of northeastern
australia the three stars that make up
orion's belt represent three brothers
fishing in the canoe when one of them
got hungry enough to break the law by
eating a sacred fish walu the sun woman
lifted them to the sky in punishment
so ancient humans all over the world
used the sky to learn and teach
traditions to navigate and keep time
unfortunately so many people today are
prevented from connecting to the stars
in the same way our ancestors did
according to the dark sky association a
non-profit dedicated to ensuring that
everyone has access to the night sky
about 80 percent of the world's
population has a diminished view of the
sky because of light and air pollution
but losing access to the stars doesn't
have to be an inevitable casualty of
scientific progress through policy and
individual action we can reduce
atmospheric pollution of all kinds and
have more of a say in what we see when
we look up
maybe one day i'll even be able to see
more than just a handful of stars from
my new york city apartment a girl can
dream can she in the meantime there are
plenty of apps you can use to acquaint
yourself with the night sky and track
constellations as they spin above you
even if you can't see them
just knowing they're there will connect
you to all of the humans who have
contemplated the stars before you
[Music]